aujourd'hui je vous parle du samsung
galaxy à 71 qui est le même mais en
mieux
le même par rapport à un smartphone dont
je vous ai déjà parlé ya quelques jours
c'est le galaxy à 51 à quelque chose
près on a la même boîte c'est quasiment
la même chose on est vraiment dans les
mêmes codes sauf qu'ils ont
effectivement ça change vous le voyez on
a un set et pas 1 5
sinon c'est sensiblement la même chose
menad et même boîte
un petit détail près pour smartphones
c'est quasiment la même chose on trouve
le capteur d'empreintes digitales aux
petits pour déverrouiller extrêmement
facilement on retrouve le petit point
son rang au qui verriez logis votre
caméra de selphy débord qui sont quand
même très fin sur les côtés en eau et un
montant qu'ils traiteraient fois en bas
la même disposition au niveau des
boutons la même prise usb ces mêmes
hauts parleurs même micro même prise
jack même que voir carte sim avec double
nanocyl plus carte micro sd même micro
réduction de bruit même disposition pour
la partie photo même brandi on a des
reflets avec des lignes on a des formes
géométriques facile vous les voyez bien
qu'ils situe ici avec un petit
croisement juste là c'est pas forcément
évident à voir comme ça on a quasiment
le même design entre le samsung galaxy à
70 élus à 51 une des différences qu'on
va voir avec ce samsung galaxy ya 71
c'est qu'il est un peu plus lourd il
fait 179 g au lieu de 172 g autant dire
que c'est vraiment pas exemple il est
légèrement plus long au lieu de faire
158,5 com fait le galaxy 51 il fait 163
2 6 mhz au lieu de faire 73,6 il fait 76
par contre en épaisseur au lieu de faire
7,9
il fait 7 5 mm on a le même écran
infiniti ou au lieu d'avoir une
diagonale de 6 5 pouces on est diagonale
de 6 7 pouces c'est une dalle super
amoled plus même résolution 2400 par
1080 pixels
c'est du full hd plus je vous conseille
exactement la même chose que ce que je
faisais conseiller sur le samsung galaxy
s 51 vous venez dans l'affichage dans le
mode vous mettez en mode vif vous venez
le réchauffé légèrement par défaut il
est en mode naturel c'est un peu moins
terrible mode vif vous le chauffer un
petit peu plus et si vous le souhaitez
qu'on aime activer le filtre de lumière
bleue qui va venir julien votre écran
mais kg à être pas mal pour vos yeux
la partie audio c'est exactement la même
eau parleur mono est ici une toute
petite prise jack pour venir brancher un
casque ou alors du bluetooth 5.0 pour
écouter avec un casque sans fil tout
comme sur galaxy à 51 la partie audio
est pas complètement dingue
elle fait le taf c'est à ces médiums on
est sur un smartphone
i'm on va pas non plus lui demander la
lune une des différences notables
viennent la partie performance sur le
galaxy à 51 vous avez un exynos 9600 ce
couple est à 4 gigas de ram
ici vous avez un snapdragon 730 couple
est assis giga de ram
vous allez donc avoir plus de
performances une meilleure fluidité ce
qu'il faut retenir
en termes d'usagés c'est que vos
applications s'ouvrir plus vite vous
allez pouvoir naviguer facilement passer
d'une application à l'autre plus
facilement vous et faire tourner
quasiment les mêmes jeux entre le galaxy
à 51 et les galaxies à 71 la différence
sur le galaxy à 71 ça sera plus rapide
et plus fluide donc une meilleure
expérience globale et fait un petit
benchmark seront tous touchent pas si
vous le savez c'est un logiciel qui vous
permet de donner une note à votre
smartphone en fonction de ses
caractéristiques techniques pour voir un
petit peu ce qu'il en est d'un point de
vue performances et on avait ce résultat
là on avait donc le résultat de 173 1196
pour le galaxy à 51 et sur le galaxy à
on a le score de 275 1636 il ya une
vraie différence c'est notable et ça
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est en toute
une différence entre lieux à 51 élus à
71 c'est la batterie sur le à 50 heures
vous avez une batterie de 4000 millions
père à tous avec batterie de 4500 millan
perreur il des différences avec le
galaxy à 51 c'est la compatibilité avec
la charge 25 watts pour la partie ouest
on tourne sans surprise sur one day 2
qui va parfaitement bien qui fait
parfaitement le taf tout ça basé sur un
android 10 soit la partie photo c'est
quasiment la même chose que vous
retrouvez sur galaxy à 51 à une seule
différence c'est celui alors récapitule
très très rapidement ici c'est pour le
mode portrait 5 mégapixels couvre f 2.2
ici vous avez quelque chose qui vraiment
différent c'est votre grand angle votre
caméra principale avec un capteur de 64
mégapixels et une ouverture de f 1.8
au lieu d'avoir ici 1,48 mégapixels tour
f 2.0 comme s'engage ainsi à 51
vous avez en somme si votre
ultra-grand-angle comme son galaxy à 51
c'est à dire 12 mégapixels de 123 degrés
qui ouvre à f 2.2 et vous avez ici votre
caméra macro de 5 mégapixels tandis qu'à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de celle
fille de 30 2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.2 toute la partie photo c'est la même
chose
vidéo super stabiliser une mode portrait
ans cette fille la seule différence vous
allez avoir c'est au niveau du rendu
grâce à cette caméra de 64 mégapixels
comme sur le galaxy à 51 pour vos photos
vous n'avez absolument aucune
stabilisation optique
voici les photos que j'ai fait à new
york toute la partie photo vous allez
voir on a quasiment les mêmes résultats
que ce qu'on peut retrouver avec le
samsung galaxy à 51 à une différence
près regarder capteur principal ça fait
le taf
on passe sur l' ultra grand-angle a une
fois de plus une vraie différence de
colorimétrie là on est un petit peu plus
clair et un peu plus blanc voyez sur la
partie centrale
là on a un côté un petit peu plus orangé
avec un peu moins de précision
là j'ai tenté la macro bon c'était
vraiment histoire de le résultat de
toute façon n'est pas terrible je vous
renvoie plus à monter du galaxy à 51
pour voir ça capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle différence de
colorimétrie est un peu celui ci y voyez
une petite déformation ici ça vient
légèrement déformé l'image capteur
principal ultra grand-angle et là je
viens zoom et zoomer dès que vous vous
rapprochez vous de suite voyez c'est pas
terrible
après c'est pas anormal et si on n'a pas
de tels objectifs on a uniquement un
zoom numérique et forcément on perd en
qualité capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle c'est moins précis
c'est moins beau les quatre principales
quand même un peu mieux je trouve que ce
qu'on peut retrouver sur le galaxy à 51
on va gagner un peu en qualité on va
gagner en luminosité surtout sur les
parties du livre effectivement essayé un
grand soleil dont vous n'êtes pas
forcément vous en rendre compte mais ça
fait le taff capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle c'est assez moyen mais
ça fait le boulot
celle ci revient sous mais on perd tout
de suite voyez ça commence un peu alice
et on le voit sur l'arbre on le voit sur
le building devant c'est pas
extraordinaire
il a dès qu'on vient souiller davantage
tout de suite s'est perdue ça moche
ultra-grand-angle capteur principal est
là on vient où met on vient vous mais ea
c'est pas terrible alors là on n'en
parlait pas ultra grand-angle capteur
principal c'est beaucoup mieux dès qu'on
commence à gaz ou mais on le voit là au
niveau des branches voyez il ya une
petite zone blanche qui vient se
dessiner autour ici pas si vous voyez
bien ça c'est l'ia qui viennent qui peut
vous aider à améliorer votre photo est
ce que vous venez zoomer mais bon bref
c'est pas extraordinaire
on vient jouer un peu plus on le voit la
vrille et toute cette partie blanche là
qui fait autour c'est vraiment l'ia qui
a reconnu que des branches qui vient un
peu comme les détours et c'est un peu
l'idée pour mieux les faire ressortir
mais bon voilà ça fait tâche mais c'est
pas extraordinaire
elle a roulé sur le mode nuit sais pas
si vous en rendez compte on est au musée
d'histoire naturelle à new york c'est
extrêmement sont ils fait quasiment nuit
dans cette pièce pour bien faire
ressortir les vitrines que vous avez là
et ça on le voit pas aussi clair même
serait une ouverture de f 1.8 on voit
que la qualité est pas extraordinaire
tente de me rapprocher zoom un peu plus
ça me rajoute une espèce de grains moche
c'est pas beau ça lycée vraiment pas
extraordinaire la même photo prise d'en
haut c'est pareil voyez tout le
traitement d'image c'est la voix
effectivement qu'on voit qu'avec ce
bonne nuit
eh bien on a pas de la magie regardez ça
là ces lycées c'est pas beau la même
chose sur l' ultra grand-angle en mode
nuit parce que oui effectivement menu on
pas voir du très grand angle on a
vraiment un résultat qui est pas beau
avec un espèce de grand
dégoûtant salissent c'est vraiment pas
terrible pour moi c'est à oublier un
t-rex en caméra principale luttera grand
tango ne fait plus la différence de
couleur et on vient nous met une fois de
plus on perd en qualité c'est
extraordinaire ultra grand-angle caméra
principale et là on vient sauver
ultra-grand-angle caméra principale a
déclenché ailleurs state building voyez
soit caméra principale
ça fait le taf c'est quand même pas mal
on a ici bien évidemment du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé pour samsung paye
vous avez du bluetooth je me dis 5.0
pour ni relié à un casque sans fils sans
aucun problème du wifi 5 une double sim
mais également une carte microsd jusqu'à
512 giga de stockage en gros c'est un
smartphone qui est relativement complet
dans le milieu de gamme qui est le même
mais en mieux que le samsung galaxy à 51
1 seul point près si au niveau du tarif
parce qu'il coûte 100 euros plus cher
regardez ma prise de notes là où le
galaxy à 51 coups de 379 euros lui coûte
479 euros 100 euros de plus maintenant
la question c'est est-ce que vous devez
mettre 100 euros de plus pour avoir ce
produit plutôt que le galaxy à 51 c'est
vraiment la question à se poser
vis-à-vis de ce produit il effectivement
mieux on a un écran qui est un peu plus
grand il sera plus performant il sera un
peu plus endurant il sera un peu
meilleur avec le capteur principal
puisque vous avez 60 4 mégapixels au
lieu de 48 mégapixels mais au-delà de ça
il n'y a pas d'énorme différence non
plus alors on va se prendre deux
secondes on pas des choses à plat on va
c'est un petit peu pragmatique
est ce que pour vous il ya une vraie
différence entre un écran de 6 5 à 6 5
pouces pour moi c'est kif kif
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une grosse
différence entre une batterie 4000
milliards eur al masri 4500 milliards
perreur vous allez dans un peu plus
d'autonomie mais c'est pas bien ça qui
va justifier la différence de 100 euros
ce qui va vraiment le justifier il ya
deux points principaux il ya
effectivement le fait d'avoir le
snapdragon 730 qui va être plus
performant qui vous permettra d'avoir
une meilleure expérience augmenter si
giga de ram plus de fluidité et bien
évidemment cette caméra de 64000 capic
celle qui sera meilleur que la 40 8
mégapixels que vous pouvez retrouver
dans le galaxy à 51 donc les deux points
que deux femmes différentes il justifié
ces 100 euros d'écart qui sont faites
très important on n'est pas sur un
produit à 1000 euros ou 100 euros
effectivement ça reste toujours une
somme mais 100 euros par rapport à
migros bon ça se réfléchit un petit peu
moins la campagne sur un smartphone à
379 euros ou 479 euros
c'est quand même très grosse partie du
prix est ce que ça vaut le coup oui ou
non la question à se poser c'est est ce
que voulaient des photos a plu
optimiser et est ce que vous voulez un
smartphone un peu plus fluide c'est
vraiment la différence
si vous répondez à ces points si pour
vous la fluidité la performance est
vraiment le point de détail au niveau de
la caméra photo est vraiment important
allez samsung galaxy s 71 5 mars à qui
quand même plutôt pas mal
assez complet et qui fera le taf si par
contre le fait que votre smartphone fois
un tout petit peu moins performant il
fait très bien l'affairé rassurez-vous
lui à 51 quand même très bien également
relativement cool et s'il fait de ne pas
avoir la meilleure définition niveau des
photos n'est pas ce qu'est le plus
important pour vous et bien ce moment là
allez sur le samsung galaxy à 51 qui
avec ses 3 179 euros ne vous décevra pas
voilà dites moi ce que vous en pensez
vous maintenant en bas en commentaire
est ce que vous avez acheté le galaxy à
51 ans est ce que vous allez acheter
galaxie 1,71 contrôle et de smartphones
d'un qu'elle va votre coeur le choix de
la raison le choix du coeur marquer ma
tous arborent commentaires que vous avez
des questions ou interrogations
suggestion vous pouvez y aller le club
bien évidemment à laisser les jolies
pousse à vous abonner à activer la
cloche tout ça se passe juste ici en
dessous de clac clac vous pouvez y aller
vous activer sur ce je vous donne rendez
vous extrêmement rapidement parce qu'on
va continuer à parler de samsung est
encore plein de choses à dire c'est la
grosse période pas si vous avez vu au
mois de septembre c'est la grosse
période apple là en ce moment c'est la
grosse période samsung sur tous les
smartphones qui sont sortis en même
temps selon la plupart en tout début
d'année aux cellules constituent les
galaxy s 20s 20 pouces 16 20 ultra
d'ailleurs y'a mon test du sv y traquer
les a sortis le galaxy z flip que je
vous ai déjà présenté le teste également
déjà sorti les galaxies buzz plus vous
êtes déjà sorti le test il ya beaucoup
de produits de samsung c'est plutôt cool
parce que la marque vraiment
intéressante et on continue on continue
avec le galaxy s 20 le galaxy s 20 plus
ça fait donc une grosse actu 5 sauvés
sur ce je vous fais des gros bisous
donne rendez vous dès demain pour
continuer par le tec allée des bisous
aller maintien
[Musique]